Hi, my name's David Hartmann.
I work for Walt Disney Entertainment in the art department as art director.
This time of year, we're decorating the Magic Kingdom for fall and for Halloween.
So if you look around on Main Street USA,...
...you'll notice there are lots of pumpkins.
There's actually 182 pumpkins.
This year, we got to redesign all the hand carved pumpkins...
...that you see all over the buildings.
The designs, we got to go crazier; we have different colors, different shapes.
The designs vary from Disney characters...
...to theming in the buildings, theming in the windows.
So, if you're looking for new ideas to design your pumpkins,...
...don't stick to the same old square, rectangles.
Do think something different, do it something exciting.
Do something like I did.
There's a snowman pumpkin.
I did a clown pumpkin,...
...so you can do all kinds of creative and exciting things.
I even have some pumpkins that resemble some of my friends.
Casey's Corner has a hotdog.
Over at the ice cream shop, there is a sundae.
There's even an ice cream cone that's falling off of the cone and laying down on the side.
Growing up in Saint Louis, Missouri....
...and coming here, living my dream of decorating the Magic Kingdom for fall...
...it's one of the most exciting things.
Standing here on Main Street and watching someone walk by...
...and smile as they look at the pumpkin...
...brings me all kinds of excitement and joy...
...and makes me feel like the four-year-old I was...
...when I used to come here as a little kid.
Happy Halloween everybody.